[ __ ] so do you make your own memes that
you put like you're really active on
Twitter so how do you come out like how
do you come up with memes and how do you
like where do you find them and how do
you curate them you were talking about
I'm curious like how do you find memes
now like what you're you're in your
twenties right yeah I'm 32 I'm a little
old for the Internet so like my meme
resource is like middle class fancy and
[ __ ] Steve and anytime I try to go
on like 4chan all I end up with is like
gaping buttholes and it's just like I
can't find anything on they don't
doesn't disgust me I don't do fortunes
like so what do you yeah and like that
aren't just that honestly I'd either I
make them myself or like I got a bunch
of homies that like I just text back and
forth just dumb ass [ __ ] and like you
know Savage realm sandwich wrong no okay
he's funny as his e memes are [ __ ]
hilarious I thought I thought because
you guys are kind of like on the same
meme level you guys are like my
recognized guys are on that tier yeah
yeah I might recognize this [ __ ] if I
see it but uh yeah not doing like I
usually get my muse from the homies or
like I make my own chicken house though
yeah now like I just I have one like
album in my in my phone like one camera
roll just full of like it's the dumbest
[ __ ] ever dude like I do like that uh I
go back to Joy's idak but that that
slideshow that slideshow video where
like it has the lyrics on the top in the
bottom yeah that's amazing
I had a homie - that works at a zoo in
Florida me and him we're just sending
pictures back and forth so hey like
jokes haddock memes and [ __ ] so like
really it didn't take no effort to make
that to make that slideshow thing I just
do it cuz I already had all the pictures
I did I just do the legs on it like boom
but ya know I make all of my memes
myself do like I use like a bunch like
video editing apps and you know the
little photo editing apps whatever I
mean it's it's honestly it's it's it's a
travel a narrative because like it's
just like being a comedian like
if you're doing stand-up I want you to
either stand up to you know comedians
bomb oh yeah I'll post some [ __ ] it's no
love at all yeah yes you know what works
oh you know it doesn't work you know and
you know pretty quick right right so
it's just finding that balance dude so
yeah man I'm still working at it cuz I'm
not the best do you do all the editing
on your phone yeah everything from my
phone really I just I just downloaded
this program on my laptop a couple of
days ago so I'm still trying to still
toying around with it trying to see what
works and what doesn't work but yet for
the most part everything's off the phone
they make it easy to design off your
phone now you don't even need a computer
second party apps that you can use to
just do [ __ ] on dude I got a Chromebook
bro like everything is off my phone
those things pretty legit yeah like
people think you need like just fancy
like a collab table you know I'm saying
I do like that goes what record him bro
recording yeah like a lot of my first
songs were like recorded with [ __ ]
iPhone earphones bro and like the
[ __ ] the microphone [ __ ] I was like
yeah yeah when people start out a lot of
people just get super attached to the
equipment and they think they need like
before they can do anything they just
need to have the best stuff right it's
just like an excuse to like wait longer
you know what I mean I can't I got to
get that microphone I need to get that
famers do you I need that video camera I
don't the latest Photoshop yeah yeah bro
you think like that you're not gonna get
[ __ ] done ever but that's that's so
toxic man procrastination dude like yeah
like I gotta get this in order to do
that and it it just hens the creative
process yeah when it ends the creative
process and to like you know I'm saying
when it comes to ideas and [ __ ] you know
there's a lot of times there's been a
lot of times when like me and Paulo will
be shooting and like we would I would be
like yo we got to shoot this like right
now like you don't simpler I feel like
if we wait on this [ __ ] the idea is
gonna get stale yeah
not gonna feel like you know I'm saying
not feel as excited shooting this is
yeah yeah man because you can plan and
you can plan and you can plan and like
yeah you go shoot that plan but you're
in the moment you have to recognize
those opportunities for creativity
you can't see unless you're like in the
middle of it yeah yeah and if you're
waiting for you know all the equipment
and everything to be perfect then you're
never gonna get started and you're never
gonna do anything worthwhile you gotta
start somewhere everybody gotta start
somewhere
you know say like [ __ ] a lot of people a
lot of people that uh that that you know
that that that uh that got their sound
their signature sound it was from using
bad studio equipment and it just became
their sound you know I'm saying like a
lot of this this references back to like
skateboarding videos like there's a lot
of people there's a lot of skate
photographers now in filmers that still
used the same equipment that they was
using in the early 2000s you know I'm
saying if it ain't don't fix it cuz
that's that's just their style of [ __ ]
like a lot of filmers are you UV x 100
row back running [ __ ] now but they
started out with like the worst
equipment ever yeah but that's the style
now yeah you know saying shitty basement
you know three 6 mafia you know a lot of
my said a lot of my [ __ ] that I do have
crabs here a lot of my [ __ ] that I do
now I'll tell my engineer I'm like Yoda
[ __ ] sounds too good like it sounds too
like he polished too clear and he's like
what the [ __ ] is that doesn't sound
shitty enough I'll be like you know like
it sounds too crispy man like distort it
just a little bit yeah
where's guys I get the speaker's
rattling a little bit like those sauna
do yeah man I feel like feel like it as
characteristic too you know so yeah dude
I feel like at the same time though it's
whatever works for you personally cuz
you know I'm saying there's a lot of
people have
you know crispy clear vocals you know
I'm saying crispy clear music videos and
everything is just perfect you know San
but there's some artists where you love
like the nitty-gritty lighting you know
I'm saying you know type [ __ ] to each of
them I think the Nitty Gritty stuff is
what you were saying earlier about like
being accessible to your fans and when
you keep it at that level you make it
more approachable and it feels more
human whereas like stuff like anything
that like Drake is doing or it's like
that's so unobtainable and if you're
waiting to look and sound like that then
you're never gonna do anything because
like those guys like Drake they they
look at the underground you know I'm
saying they're like what can I steal
they write right they take [ __ ] from the
underground so it's like don't try and
be like these big dudes cuz they're
trying to be like us yeah they're trying
to steal what you're doing so be
yourself and then maybe one day Drake
can rip you off yeah right yeah hey
Kenny like making songs for like tik-tok
dances now yeah yeah no actually I want
to make a tic-tac dance to my girl band
puttin me on to a tick-tock lately cuz
I'm not on tick-tock at all so I was
like damn like I need to make it like a
little take time what what a big baby
scumbags dance we're just yeah you just
go left go fast and go left and we have
something to do with beer like the
shotgun like that's the best advance I
don't know I'm not that coordinated I
can't really dance like that yeah like
there's row with tick-tock there's so
many like choreography steps and like
there's so much to do is a new one every
week yeah not or like honestly though
it's like the same five dances but it's
just like I love the way that they
dancer there's there's so much emphasis
on like every yeah
a man ya know like tick tock is lit tick
tock is for sure is where it's at you've
got a if you're like doing memes and
promoting yourself through social media
you kind of have to be reacting to
everything that's coming out whether it
was like vine which is dead now yeah but
like luckily like Instagram and Twitter
everything stuck around like that for
you and now it's like you know you take
a risk every time you go on a new
platform with a quill it tanked in a
couple of years but is that risk worth
it or
to invest the time you know back in the
day bro myspace like I would have never
thought we'd live in the world where
myspace don't exist right why myspace
was the [ __ ] they lost it though once
they had a top 16 really top that was
that was legitimate but like once you
get top 32 you know it's too much you're
trying to make it for everybody at that
point no one start to lose it bro you
know it's funny so on my top eight right
so there was there was these accounts
right so I would set my top eight to say
Deez Nuts so like there was one account
that was like D u ad D as a friend you
Eddie as a friend at E as a friend see
you just make fake accounts and you t
know like this was like real it like I
got this from my homie of Mines I had
Deez Nuts top I was like I had these
nuts to it like I put this [ __ ] in to
order this from crispy crab crispy crab
[Laughter]